Atropa belladonna will kill you.
Datura will put you to sleep forever.
Aconitum will kill you.
Laurel will produce cyanide and kill you.
Every plant here in the Poison Garden is poisonous...
...and has the ability to kill you.
My name is Trevor Jones and I'm the head gardener of Alnwick Garden.
This plant is  giant hogweed.
It will get up to around about eight foot high.
It's phototoxic, so it will burn your skin...
...and give you blisters for up to seven years.
This garden is set in the war garden of the old castle....
...in Northumberland, UK.
We have around about 95 plants...
...and we're adding to the collection all the time.
They're very, very common plants.
In fact, a lot of them are what we call cottage garden plants...
...and they're grown in many people's gardens,...
...but people don't know how harmful they actually are.
People are intrigued by poisonous plants.
I'm often very worried when they come out...
...because many of them will be growing these plants at home,...
...and they don't realize the powerful impact...
...plants can have on us humans.
Is it something that you find fascinating?
Definitely.
Why?
It's a good way to get rid of your wife.